welcome to this video t rashti gresh
something like that from canada but the
ROI can I do something out so I'm
probably candid let's stick with them
tried and trusted main line then she
going again at least I'm able to play
quickly here d 3 okay d3 and cook a form
interesting yeah there's really really a
lot of setups that white can play in the
way this is one of the slower more
positionally focused once okay yeah
maybe I should try to exchange the
bishop okay yeah if i take it 97 what do
you play c4 yeah maybe you will write
not so quick could take with the bishop
and strange as it looks okay yeah come
on let's close the whole thing on the
queenside this shouldn't be too bad
yeah the bishop here on b3 is not
exactly great so the whole position
looks quite okay to me I think but still
not clear how to continue all this I
didn't expect no actually get in Bishop
age six exchanging the bishop oh he
wants to play Bishop age for know yeah
whatever you you can say about this play
is playing very quickly it looks like a
step-by-step positional deterioration on
the white side to me but but still he's
good oops still got the standard
ringtone on the iphone so Knight f6 I
wanted to play but I cannot play because
g5s is happening now let's get slightly
annoying actually what f6 he might play
a form that should have done with the
other night we've taken the other night
okay maybe I need to do that it's not
not a big problem but it wasn't wasn't
what I had intended and F fryer maybe a
form I in g7 now this this is fine for
me but I had already had expected
something better even it's all based on
the fact that he's got this stupid
bishop on c2
ok so very nice but how do I actually
win the thing h5 yeah probably let's
let's open it up directly if you take
screen g5 is just fine for me ok
let's consider am rook rook h 4head
queen h8 or g5 actually i was g5s is the
way to to play it I guess oh yeah that's
me WI can can also be also possible
Queen f6 sg5 though better not okay if I
go here you will take so I must pledge
if I fo came to take with the pawn and
then look aged 8 yeah of course it's
very close but I have night g5 if he
takes at one point and I take with them
the pawn I have night g5 and then can
try to to advance I maybe can just play
rook h3 any way possible
yeah maybe it's too close to them I
won't want this I had the thing is he
can take if I take with the pawn you can
probably take playbook h3 and just after
95 ignore the whole thing that's also
possible
yeah that's probably not leading to
anything here time warning put the night
on g6
check
not even possible to to set up suits one
here very very much impossible to do
anything let's consider though I can try
to try to play with night to be 6 and
taking on a form if it's not really
paying attention I can do that also on
ok maybe I can combine this somehow
what's not possible unfortunately graph
advert that's some way probably yeah
probably must take ground our third game
Graham Jeff that's really a bit
disappointing because what was totally
one-sided the whole thing but maybe this
was yeah I don't know I like a split is
of course clearly better yeah but can
you win know maybe maybe I played it
that plated plated badly right this is
this is probably probably probably not
good here now in h1 I can actually go
here maybe I should do that yeah that's
much better with we're cooking with
knight on d5 I really I really botched
this up rook age 18 h 5 novel would
basically win the thing he cannot really
much I thought h5 would actually be
clever but it is not yet this this I
thought would be would be quite nice for
me opening up the position so that I can
actually enter in the long run but plus
was a nice idea but not really not
really working I'd here should probably
play Queen edge for check first here is
to close early can I don't know maybe
can't we look at this maybe I should at
one point just play h3t it was already
over I still have this idea with 96 but
he was doing over quick enough yeah
maybe now hmm if i can get 95 in an h3
this is in fact it is may be interesting
maybe i can get this in but trauma still
a draw the idea the only ideas i have an
age pawn and if i get if i get a freebie
pond then it's maybe too much for the
bishop yeah and this matter of exact
timing it's probably not possible to set
it up but this is what i'm talkin about
let's say just for for you and say this
is kind of stuff i cannot play age 3
really i mean i can i'm not losing or
anything but it's not really helping
yeah that's the draw it is too closed I
must have I must play Queen edge show
and this is much better instead of
instead of g5 here this sir
and they tried a try I mean instead of
this I must play Queen age four and then
it's it's even fairly straightforward
okay thanks for watching